[Musique]
on
à
tous
[Musique]
ce sont des fours qui ont été fabriqués
par des lycéens de lepervanche donc déjà
au démarrage du projet l'idée c'est
d'amener des fours solaires dans les
villages afin de leur permettre
d'économiser du bois de l'électricité
parce que donc c'est donc effectivement
un système qui permet d'utiliser le
soleil pour notamment chauffer l'eau on
a des fours solaires à mener dans les
villages on démonte avec les villageois
donc on a vécu déjà des super moments
assez gros v6 ou en fait beaucoup de
monde est venu et tous ont été très
contents de repartir avec leur four
[Musique]
oui
faux mode et le faux solaire faut que tu
manges est
appelé par mano gaz là le soleil pour
chauffer le lot
appelé
après le soir faut prendre le manger
pourquoi hier à manger vous pierre kary
tu toi qui a été avalisé trop du four ni
appareil
[Rires]
ça fait effectivement
[Musique]
non
comment
pour
[Musique]
comme ils sont assez pauvres ils ont pas
forcément les moyens
d'aller dans des hôpitaux ou avoir des
soins du coup nous je suis contente de
faire ce projet comme ça nous on peut
les aider même si voilà on peut pas tout
faire non plus mais c'est quand même
déjà bien ce qu'on fait j'ai appris que
l'on pouvait pas aider tout le monde
c'est triste mais que la plupart ont les
aider au moins soit sur la vision de
près ce sont la vision ses besoins
franchement ça soulage parce que moi
même si j'avais un problème de vue
j'aurais aimé que on me donne la
possibilité de arranger un peu mieux
mais vu
[Musique]
qu'on est parti
mais leur tour 20
c
témoin
la puce
[Musique]
nina est
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mardi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une
où
dumont
nous